hello
my name is sylvia paulina
during this talk we will discuss the
ludic uses of technology for
science and mathematics education
i'm a student at nam in mexico city
and i will like to start
with this abstract so
the current outbreak of sars cop2
disease has caused a restructuring
of life in society an essential aspect
that has been transformed is education
we are facing a scenario never
imagined before in which technologies
and computational thinking have a
central role
in new models of distance learning and
teaching
students need to stimulate their
cognitive
skills and teachers need to develop
their skills in the use of computational
tools
wolfram language allow us
to satisfy both needs
through a playful environment
the future of science and mathematics
education
seen from a new perspective
in which the priority is to bring
enjoyment in the understanding of the
natural world
through the programming language
thank you all the people for being here
and we will just start with the content
of this talk
first introduction and the second
science mathematics and technology
then we're going to talk about the
paradigm of computational education
the future education world from language
and goal from you and
final remarks introduction
human being splendor
undoubtedly the development of science
has been linked to the mathematical
knowledge
that the human being has of the nature
that surrounds him the first
vestige of accounting date back
to the aurachnasi era
where the man of chromagnon used bones
with several series of regularly
arranged notches
with the appearance of writing numeric
systems numerous civilizations
developed as splendor in their social
life
as as well as an impressive
development in mathematical and
astronomical knowledge
in the calculation of time and in the
calendar
in this epigraphy we can see
pacal king a maja king
this image or this representation
is considered for many people
like interpretation
of a machine in which the person
sitting there is allowed to travel
through the milky way
so this is when we think
in in this and we we see this is
um this design reminds us
exactly like a machine and all these
have sense
because the major numbering was one of
the most
advanced and exact systems
they were able to introduce the concept
of
cereal the concept of zero is one of the
most
advances in in mathematics
and well um not only
major people
[Music]
do this remarkable mathematical
creativity
we can see this creativity in babylon
in egypt in greece
whose influence lasts to this day
there is a long list of people who throw
history
contribute and nor to this relationship
between science and mathematics
in this list we can see names like
archimedes
ptolemy vitagoras but
i like to talk about women in science
and women in mathematics
the beautiful language of mathematics
and i would like to reading this quote
mathematical science shows
what is it is the language
of unseen relations between
things but to use
and apply that language we must
be able to fully appreciate
to feel to see the unseen
the unconscious i float a
pool in this talk
about what means for you mathematics
because
this quote was made by ada lovelace
i will talk about her in some minutes
but i i like to
make this and
[Music]
remem remark this about how
many mathematicians are like poets like
artists and have this view
very deep about
what means mathematics or science
for them one
woman um ipatia of alexandria
was the first person
the first woman considered the first
scientist he she
he was a teacher also
who has this interest
in teach science and mathematics in a
different way
it's it is no she use
in her classes and talk about
philosophy and talk about
ethical social problems and also involve
all these with mathematics and science
so this is amazing also
maria agnesi and
she wrote the
the most um reading
manual or the most reading book for
learning mathematics
in in europe for a long time
also she is known for his
witch problem who has
a bad translation about this
idea about all the science is related
with the devil and
all like that but it's not about witches
it's about
mathematics and geometry
the last one other lovelace or
better known as adavarion
is was the daughter of lord byron
the poet and
she was the first person who made the
first call the first program
for a computer so
it's amazing how this
this women has this idea
about change the paradigm
about how we learn science
and how we teach science and mathematics
well it's important to mention
galileo said that the book of the
universe was
writing in the mathematical language
however it was newton who demonstrated
with the publication of the principia
the relationship
between mathematics and science
natural phenomena can be explained
through
abstract and simple laws to express them
in a mathematical equations the most
important theories in the files of
physics
and chemistry of the last centuries
have been formulated in terms of
mathematical equations
this is a fact so
i would like to share it my favorite
mathematic equations and first we have
scheringer equation this is simplified
um notation and
it's one of my favorites because when
you solve the equation
you can see the geometry of hybrid
orbitals
i will show you a demonstration
in wolfram language in the following
slides but this is one of my favorites
and
also if you want to shout out what is
your favorite mathematical equation i'm
looking forward to seeing the chat
also james max maxwell equation
this is so important because this change
or
way to communicate is related with
the radio magnet files and
also with all this
communication about radio waves and
magnetism
so it's amazing also it's in a
simplified way
and the last one the edward
lawrence these three equations show
us um the theory of the
of the cows this is one of my favorite
because it explains the theory of cows
well
let's go to see how mathematics
science and technology
have a better understand how mathematics
science and technology closely
interrelate
let's let's think about
a problem a real world
problem
uh often a real world problem
often contains aspects of necessary
levels of knowledge
the goal of science is to understand
the natural world and the wall of
technology is to modify this natural
world
to meet the needs of human beings
it could be taught that in
their origin science and technology
maintain
differences that make them opposite
epistemes
these three words
reminds us what means
which it comes from episteme
with
so however they converge
in intimate
uh in the hands of assign the
observation of the natural
low plays data
and understand the phenomena when
building a numerical or or qualitative
model
whose analysis allows making decisions
designing artifacts and controlling
processes
in an efficient and reliable way
we speak of applied mathematics
where both science and technology
are unique in an essential
attribute real world mathematics
in this painting we can see a person
who has creating
birds she take
from the natural world in
their chemical flask this
energy and
by the musical instrument who is
connected
through her heart
she give life to to her creation
this is one of my favorite paintings
because
express the work of a scientist
take from the nature
and change with their hands
and with their mind by
hurt by heart
with the emerge
of modern digital and programmable
computers
we find another mathematical attribute
that you need science and technology
the new branches of theoretical
computational mathematics
appears computational science is
positioned as the third component
of the the scientific method
along with the theory and experiment
experimentation
we are faced with an alteration of the
inner interactions of galileo and newton
we are changing this paradigm about
science and mathematics
are making by theory and experimentation
we are introducing this new paradigm
the computational science
here the influence that technology has
on cultureand and the ways of relating
of a society
becomes evident a language
fabric by the intimate relationship with
science no one can deny how this
relationship directly impacts impacts
in the people's daily lives this is the
party
of computational education
by setting new directions in science and
mathematics education
for the 20th century
apparently shift influence by the new
technological tools
that will lead to new ideas and skills
and new ways of thinking about
traditional concepts
and skills is emphasized the new
computational paradigm
can open doors to more playful
environments
in teaching and learning this is very
important because
each person have their own way to learn
and their own way to teach
so we need to take advantage about these
new technologies
and implement that in our classes or in
or self learning
entering the new normal raises many
questions
regarding the scope and learning of
online's
online science and mathematics teaching
in this regard we must focus on
innovative methodological
aspects in the design and implementation
of tools and technological environments
for teaching
a deeper insight can be obtained in
terms of
potential of technology to foster a
creativity and playful programming
language multimodal and interactive
by teachers and students as well
as the digital media and tools will
branding
and enriching the transdisciplinary
and interdisciplinary
we can see in this workload some words
about
this distance learning classes we can
see wolfram
computational online courses
training mathematica programming
interactive
live coding presentations certification
well i think all of the people here
we are um we
are close to these new ways to
to work right now because the pandemic
that takes us to the future education
work from language and world from you
talking about new technological tools
to face these new paradigms in education
we propose the use of the word from
language for teaching mathematics and
science
so that being an open language
it allows us the possibility of
collaborating
with a large community of programmers
offering demonstrations that can be
enriched
and transformed i will show you
some examples from wolfram at work this
could be a good tool for sharon in
classrooms
or by self-learning spikes
is one of my favorites
you can see the this uh
in in gold from math world
you can see the document of spikes
this is really
this is really
rich
and you can see the
the the
web page i'm not quite sure if you can
see it
right now we still want to see the
presentation
oh technical issues
[Music]
maybe these mental boards
well um this is a example of
a wolfram at war you can see the
the links um
like this
oh i got it
it's here the mandelboard set
you can see the geometry and
this new approach which is more rich
than all
only see formulas
also this despite the very famous logo
of
wolfram i like it a lot
it's like artistic it's so so
yeah so artistic so
there are another examples
chemistry examples hybrid orbitals in
organic
chemistry
and this is one of my favorites
we can play with with this i refer to
the schrodinger equation
to tease so we can play
and see the every orbitals for
each every orbital
so it's like playing typically playing
um okay
[Music]
um
well about um
these examples we can find in the in the
page of demonstrations
and wall from at war also
i would like to to start to talk
about my experience in world from you
and
when we express information by means of
a mathematical model or a mathematical
equation
we'll foreign language allow us to throw
a simple
rules to encode this information to
solve
problems we will tell the computer
what to do and how to
throw this code it's much simpler to
create
new environments in which creativity is
integrated
to learn by playing it
is at this point where the playful uses
of technology
for teaching science and mathematics
converge
making them more pleasant with colorful
and animated environment than then
provide pleasure
joy and enjoyment
this is another example
i'd like to share it
we can change the molecule
this is one of my favorite caffeine
we can change color the size
so it's a new way to teach something
than we
already know and i think this is this
can
younger people can pay attention more in
into these examples than if they only
see
numbers however
it's important to have the
the basis the mathematical basis of
of these of these explanations
about wall from you
it's a platform is a free and innovative
way to start with
interactive courses in the world from
language
it includes short videos exercises
notebooks and the best of all they are
taught by professionals
webinars are an avant-garde way of
teaching
programming in which the use of new
technologies
go hand-in-hand with qualification
instructions
in collaborative mutual learning
environment in which you can develop
your creativity
so through recreational tools
the close relationship between
mathematics and science
dates back to the time in memorial this
relationship
plays a central role in solving real
world
problems technology and science converge
on attributes that are essential and
each version of technology from
primitive human techniques to current
computer technology
acquires control over a cultural or a
social situation
from a scientist approach the new
normality
requires the creation of innovative
pedagogical environments for the
teaching
of science and mathematics what foreign
language do
to these characteristics provides a
multimodal
and interdisciplinary environment in
which
we can learn by playing through the
programming code
world from you is an innovative platform
which enables certification and
self-taught
distance learning via online
the future of education seen from a new
perspective
through the incorporation of welfare
language
allow us to satisfy the needs of
teachers
and students in this new normal
thank you so much to my niece to my
family welfare research my instructors
involved from you
albritta chakravarti rory fulger and
jayanta
my teachers at una and all the people
who attended
this lecture thank you so much